COME OUT OF KYIV.
TREY YENGST THERE.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT BIDEN SPEAKS
TODAY ON RUSSIA'S FULL SCALE
INVASION AND MANY ARE WONDER
WHAERG THE U.S. CAN DO AT THIS
POINT TO STOP THE VIOLENCE.
LET'S BRING IN BRET BAIER.
THE PRESIDENT MET VIRTUALLY
WITH THE G-7 LEADERS THIS
MORNING.
HE WAS SCHEDULED TO SPEAK AT
NOON AND WE'VE JUST FOUND OUT
THAT HAS BEEN PUSHED A LITTLE
BIT TO 12:30 P.M.
ARE YOU HEARING ANYTHING?
>> THAT MEETING IN THE
SITUATION ROOM WITH HIS
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL AND
VIRTUAL MEETING WITH THE G-7
LEADERS.
GERMANY IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
G-7 THIS YEAR TALKING ABOUT
NEXT STEPS.
TALKING ABOUT THE NEXT TRONCH
OF SANCTIONS.
THIS WAS A TIERED APPROACH.
THE FIRST TRONCH GOT CRITICISM
FOR NOT BEING HARD ENOUGH.
THIS NEXT LEVEL OF SANCTIONS IS
A DIFFERENT BALLGAME ACCORDING
TO OFFICIALS WE'RE TALKING TO.
IN THAT MEETING THIS MORNING,
ALSO THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE
AND STATE AND TREASURY.
TREASURY PLAYING A SIGNIFICANT
ROLE IN HOW SANCTIONS ARE
ROLLED OUT ACROSS THE WORLD.
THE DANGER OBVIOUSLY IS THAT
OTHER COUNTRIES IN EUROPE WILL
FEEL THIS DIRECTLY WHEN THESE
SANCTIONS ESPECIALLY ON ENERGY
ARE DEPLOYED.
BUT STOPPING PUTIN IS THE
NUMBER ONE GOAL.
>> Bill: YOU WERE LISTENING TO
KARL A MOMENT AGO.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING OR
THINKING OR ANALYZING WHEN IT
COMES TO THE STRENGTH THAT THE
AMERICAN PRESIDENT MUST SHOW
TODAY?
>> I THINK THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S WHOLE PLAYBOOK IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHENEVER HE
SPEAKS HE SPEAKS WITH ALL OF
THE WORLD LEADERS, THE ALLIES
STANDING BY HIS SIDE AND
ESSENTIALLY SINGING FROM THE
SAME SHEET OF MUSIC AND GETTING
MORE POWERFUL IN THE MESSAGE HE
IS DELIVERING.
I WAS INTERESTED TO SEE THE
U.K. PRIME MINISTER BORIS
JOHNSON AND HIS REMARKS THIS
MORNING.
HE OBVIOUSLY CRITICIZED AND
LAMBASTED THE MOVE BY PUTIN AND
SAID THE WORLD NEEDS TO STOP IT
BUT HE WENT ON TO SAY HOW
IMPORTANT THIS WAS FOR THE
WORLD BECAUSE IT SENDS A
MESSAGE ELSEWHERE AND HE
SPECIFICALLY IS TALKING ABOUT
CHINA AND TAIWAN.
JUST THIS MORNING TAIWANESE
DEFENSE MINISTRY SAID NINE
CHINESE AIRPLANES CROSSED INTO
THEIR AIRSPACE AND CHINESE
GOVERNMENT SAID TAIWAN IS NOT
UKRAINE AND TAIWANESE PRESIDENT
UPPED THE MILITARY ALERT IN
TAIWAN.
WE WERE LOOKING THROUGH KYIV
AND IT IS DANGEROUS AND THERE
WILL BE FIGHTING AND PEOPLE
WILL CONTINUE TO DIE BUT
BROADER THERE IS A BIGGER
MESSAGE FOR THE WORLD.
>> Dana: SPEAKING OF THAT, IF
YOU GO BACK TO 1994 AND THE
AGREEMENT THAT WAS MADE AS
UKRAINE GAVE UP ITS NUCLEAR
WEAPONS AS PART OF THAT
BUDAPEST MEETING THAT WE WOULD
HELP PROTECT UKRAINE.
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT.
SO AMERICA AND THE WEST ONCE
AGAIN -- I GUESS YOU COULD SAY
WE PROVIDED THEM SOME AID.
I THINK FOR THE UKRAINIANS WILL
THINK THIS IS NOT ENOUGH AS
THEY FLEE TO THE WEST.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS GETTING
READY TO GIVE A STATE OF THE
UNION ADDRESS IN A FEW DAYS AND
THIS NEXT FEW DAYS WILL BE
EXTREMELY BUSY FOR HIM AND HE
WILL HAVE TO SHOW A LOT OF
STRENGTH AND THEY ARE PLANNING
TO BE IN THE CHAMBER ON TUESDAY
NIGHT WITH A REDUCED SIZE CROWD
WITH EVERYONE HAVING TO BE
MASKED UP, EVEN THOUGH MOST OF
THE REST OF THE WORLD HAS MOVED
ON FROM THE PANDEMIC AND
FIGURING OUT A WAY TO LIVE WITH
IT.
IT FEELS A LITTLE DISCORDANT AS
WE HEAD INTO THE STATE OF THE
UNION.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT WILL BE A CHALLENGE FOR THIS
PRESIDENT TO STREAM AND TIE ALL
OF THOSE THINGS TOGETHER IN A
COHERENT MESSAGE.
THIS TAKES CENTER ISSUE.
WE HAVE BIGGER ISSUES.
NOW WITH CRUDE OIL AND OIL
HITTING $105 FOR -- YOU START
THINKING ABOUT THE IMPLICATIONS
FOR AMERICANS DOWN THE ROAD.
THERE WILL BE A LOT I THINK IN
THE SPEECH TODAY ABOUT THE
COSTS AND SUFFERING THAT WE AS
AMERICANS MAY FACE.
>> Bill: THANK YOU, BRET.
WE'LL BE BACK WITH YOU SHORTLY